for 70 years the European Union and the
project of European unification has been
a vital strategic interest in the United
States that's not all of a sudden going
to change you know I think these
strategic interest these these these
long and deep relationships we've had
with the United States they are not
going to change suddenly I'm quite sure
that once you know if you also look at
the hearings in Congress of people who
are going to fill responsible positions
in the Trump administration they all
commit to NATO they're very strong about
NATO they are very realistic about the
relationship with Russia and they are
also very realistic about the need to
have a strong relationship with Europe
you know the fact that we share
fundamental values between these two
societies that's not going to change do
you think you share the same values now
than you did you know a month a few
months ago well I'm not talking just
about politicians but if you look at
what people deem important in our
societies no liberty the possibility for
self-development the possibility to be
able to be success in society the
possibility to have access to education
on the basis of your talents the need to
take care of people who are in a
difficult situation so this is stuff
that every country you know every
country says it well it believes it but
but i think you know if you look
especially the issue of freedom is not
perceived in the same way across the
world and we do have a lot in common
with the Americans if you look at
freedom and I think this is not going to
change with a new administration right
okay but you know one of the things that
Donald Trump has said is that he
believes that others will leave others
will leave the European Union well you
know what we've seen since the brexit
vote is 27 member states coming together
and being very clear about the fact that
they want to find common issues to fight
for and I think paradoxically you've
seen EU countries moving closer together
rather than being
apart since the brexit booked so I have
not seen one member state expressing the
wish to follow the the British example
I've rather even seen some of the
politicians are very critical of the EU
no longer advocating that country
leaving me you but it will say we don't
want to be in the euro were critical of
this and that but this call for leaving
the European Union has not increased its
rather diminished since the brexit code
okay in talking of brac say what was
your reaction to Theresa May's speech
yesterday well first of all I think she
confirmed in a speech what one could
have already seen on the basis of her
political declarations before too and a
surprise though in terms of the content
of speech I wasn't I wasn't surprised at
all it's it's a confirmation we thought
would be coming in terms of the tone of
the speech I was surprised that she was
very positive about how she would see a
future relationship with EU and that she
wants to you to be a success without the
UK but still she wants it to be a
success I mean that the positive tone is
it I think would be a good start for for
our negotiations but the end of the day
we simply have to wait for the
notification of article 50 and what that
notification will will entail and then
we could start negotiate but there were
some specifics and the single market you
know a lot of people in Europe and in
the UK thought the UK would stay in the
single market even if it left the EU
that is a big deal isn't it for her to
say that a signal that we would leave
the single market but she's been saying
for quite some time that the UK would
not accept the European judiciary that
the UK would not accept the freedom of
movement well if that is your line that
of course the internal market becomes a
very difficult proposition if not
impossible propositions those things are
impossible yes the phone is still
incompatible well you know yesterday is
where the freedom of movement the four
freedoms of the you are an essential
part of our legal obligations they're
not just a political agreement they form
a part and parcel of the treaty so if
you don't want that that means that you
take a step away from
the treaty including the internal mark
so in that sense I felt her speech
yesterday as a confirmation of something
we were expecting and finally just
quickly or are you sanguine about the
economic implications for Europe and for
the UK of leading the single well I
think we all have a responsibility on
both sides of the channel to make sure
that we do as little harm as possible to
our economies i think that is that is
really a responsibility we have visa vie
our citizens and our businesses I mean
in this day and age you need to be very
careful to make sure that your economy
is in a good position to grasp global
opportunities but it's in no way easy so
we we should do the best we can make
sure that on both sides of the channel
we come out of this with a very little
harm but to the Yukon hum is it harmful
to leave a single market well we'll
we'll have to wait and see I strongly
believe in the single market I do
believe that Europe as an actor on the
global scale needs a single mark to be
strong enough to also in the future
grasp the opportunities that this
industrial revolution offers and I
believe that we need to be strong and
500 million are stronger than a more
limited number